[Música]
nuevamente hablamos de economía en
directo américa de france24 àngel
hablando vamos a hablar de la comisión
europea que propuso un plan de
emergencia sobre gas así es de raúl este
plan se llama ahorra gas para un
invierno seguro y es que ahora en verano
relativamente tienen gas pero el
problema vendrá en invierno este plan
consiste en que los países del bloque
comunitario reduzcan en un 15% su
consumo de gas entre el próximo primero
de agosto y el 31 de marzo de 2023 esta
reducción es frente a los últimos años y
ese hace para prepararse ante un posible
corte del suministro por parte de rusia
las maneras de hacerlo entonces serían
bajando la temperatura de los
termostatos limitando la calefacción o
el aire acondicionado en edificios
públicos y ofreciendo incentivos a la
industria para que usen combustibles
alternativos cuando sea posible o
reduzcan también el consumo de gas este
reglamento necesita aprobación final de
todos los miembros que podría darse a
finales de esta semana y las medidas son
voluntarias pero no se descarta que
algunas puedan ser obligatorias cuando
detecte un grave riesgo de escasez le
preguntó a ni qué tan grave actualmente
es esta situación
bueno antes de la guerra rusia ya
suministraba un 40% del gas natural a
europa y podemos dimensionar lo la
situación ahora la describe mejor la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
font d'en rellena las casas el flujo de
gas ruso ahora es menos de un tercio de
lo que solía ser por ejemplo en la misma
época del año pasado ryan black mailings
y
rusia no se está chantajeando está
utilizando la energía como arma y por lo
tanto en cualquier caso si hay un corte
parcial e importante del gas ruso o un
corte total
europa necesita estar lista bueno a todo
esto se suma a raúl que el gasoducto
nord stream 1 como lo hemos venido
informando que es el mayor transportador
de gas ruso hacia europa por el mar
báltico está en mantenimiento de 10 días
mañana se cumplen esos 10 días y debería
reiniciar operaciones pero hay quienes
ven probable que se ha cortado
totalmente este suministro por eso es
que europa está hacia usted ahorra gas o
no o raúl yo si realmente yo no soy muy
consumidor de gas pues lo que uno cocina
y el calentador cuando uno se baña pero
pues no trate de bañarme por mucho largo
tiempo pero le tengo una mala noticia y
es que los usuarios somos los que menos
gastamos ganaron los que realmente
gastan us son las empresas a esa
industria es que hay que apuntarle en
esta reducción que vamos a ver entonces
qué van a hacer si por qué por si no que
tanto gas usa dan y vamos a cambiar la
información porque el primer reto
económico del nuevo presidente decir y
créeme zinc es era el acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional
que viene adelantando hace varios meses
sin éxito todavía y es que este país
asiático de más de 20 millones de
habitantes se ha visto afectado por una
gravísima escasez de combustible
alimentos y otros elementos esenciales
después de que se agotaran sus reservas
de divisas inclusive hace algunas
semanas se dijo que la economía había
colapsado el medio japonés nikkei citó a
la directora gerente del organismo del
fondo monetario internacional kristalina
georgieva diciendo que espera completar
las conversaciones de rescate lo más
rápido posible pero para obtener esa
ayuda el fm y ha pedido asilo y blanca
reformas fiscales urgentes también ha
destacado entre los dos principales
desafíos el elevado nivel de inflación y
las presiones de la balanza de pagos es
decir en los dólares el organismo
multilateral exige también reducir la
corrupción que es uno de los grandísimos
problemas estructurales en sí de la ncaa
bueno anhelamos un tema que yo sé que a
usted le encanta y pues a mí
es que me disguste vamos a hablar de la
pelea entre hilo en mos y twitter que ya
tiene fecha de juicio en los tribunales
y veníamos hablando claro raúl y es que
esta es una de las grandes peleas podría
configurarse como la gran pelea de wall
street para este año pero esta década en
youtube por sus dimensiones económicas y
es que después de que el multimillonario
y los moscas se arrepintiera de pagar
unos 44 mil millones de dólares por la
red social 'twitter' lo llevó a un
pleito en un tribunal de delaware que es
especializado precisamente en estos
conflictos empresariales
ahora se inicia sin iniciar esta guerra
la empresa ya ganó su primera pequeña
batalla porque el juez del caso fijo
para octubre la fecha de inicio del
juicio que durará apenas cinco días pues
considera que twitter se merece una
solución rápida a la incertidumbre del
acuerdo mosca había presionado para que
se realizara en febrero de 2023 por la
complejidad de este caso pues el abogado
de twitter calificó el hecho como un
intento de sabotaje y aseguró que
también dueño de spacex está haciendo
todo lo posible por derivar a la
compañía a lo que sus abogados
respondieron que si fuera de esta manera
no tendría hoy una participación
accionaria tan alta en la empresa se
estima que es alrededor del 9 por ciento
de tweety por esto pelean danny claro
por eso pelean porque me de raúl cuando
el en abril de este año y lo en los que
decidió comprar twitter mira la acción
costaba o no la acción cosa o no él
ofreció 54,2 dólares y ofreció 44 mil
millones de dólares ahora hoy la empresa
cuesta 30 mil millones de dólares en
bolsa y la acción cuesta 39 dólares y
154 dólares entonces nadie querría pagar
ese exceso de dinero por una empresa que
ya no vale tanto como valía cuando
decidió comprarla e naw dije 'bueno
daniela y nuevo récord del dólar en
argentina sigue imparable sigue
imparable las cotizaciones en los
diversos mercados cambiarios que
coexisten en este país batieron el
martes nuevos récords hay que recordar
que en argentina existen por lo menos
día tipos de dólar diferente en el
mercado informal el dólar superó la
barrera psicológica de los 300 pesos
argentinos y el dólar formal en el banco
de la nación subió en una sola jornada
más de 50 pesos a un máximo de 135 75
pesos el precio del dólar entonces en
argentina ha venido subiendo de forma
muy sostenida desde finales de junio
último cuando se suman en restricciones
para el acceso a las divisas y luego de
que renunciará el ministro de economía
martín guzmán en medio de todas estas
tensiones financieras y políticas
también en éste para indicadores
económicos han y las acciones raúl
avanzaron en asia este miércoles después
de que wall street' repuntará a su mejor
día en más de tres semanas con alzas
cercanas al 3% la jornada anterior esto
ocurrió debido a que varias empresas
reportaron fuertes ganancias en el
segundo trimestre por el contrario los
mercados europeos si caen allí es
noticia bursátil que la empresa francesa
total en el ies se retiró
definitivamente de mianmar como lo han
hecho muchas compañías internacionales
que se oponen al golpe de estado de 2021
cifra el día
240 mil 280 dólares cuesta en promedio
una vivienda en reino unido estos 12 8%
más que hace un año y le doy la cifra en
libras esterlinas también para que usted
decidan que lo quiere pagar como robe
283 mil 496 en libras esterlinas cuesta
una casa en promedio en promedio danny
como siempre muchísimas gracias por toda
la información económica nos vemos
mañana con más economía derecha américa
de france 24 y pasamos a hablar con un
maresca de deportes